so my greek grandmother would be like
you said like she watched something on
tv i'm not i'm not even joking she
watched somebody she goes you see that
singer she'd be like he's good
he must be greek it was [ __ ] fine
like lionel richie no no i can see his
hair that's greek
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god
hola with me george lopez
let's do the show
you know what george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
oh my god
hey everybody this is producer grant
here just a reminder if you like the
show if you're enjoying the show please
like comment subscribe on any platform
you're checking it out on whether that's
on youtube whether that's apple podcast
spotify anything any engagement that we
have really really helps we all serve
the almighty algorithm these days and
any amount that you sort of interact
with the show in any way just really
helps us out helps us get cooler guests
for the show helps raise the profile for
the show helps give us more content for
you guys to enjoy so thanks again for
checking it out and please enjoy the
episode
in the time that we've been doing this
have we nailed the idea that of why
people are fascinated with true crime no
i have no idea
what is it it's crazy because that's
what that's why law and order's been on
for 30 years that's why but it's not
just a [ __ ] few people it's it's
everybody
that you don't expect people in general
like see i don't follow that [ __ ]
because
to me it was work it was a real case you
know murdered and i know and i know it's
people [ __ ] better imagine that you
it was work to him that's what that's
your work so you're right
i loved my job i really hit i i loved it
but what you see
are people that want to solve cases
because they think you know the clue
that's like playing the game of clue
yeah you know colonel muster did in the
kitchen with a rope you know so
they they watch these things and that's
what they they the intrigue of trying to
solve in the end yeah i know because i
have
my wife and one of my daughters really
into this
dad dad what do you think what do you
think you know it occupies so much of
what's out there on every on every
uh streaming platform
it does and what's really sad too is
when you see the detective
who didn't figure it out and retired and
then they're talking saying it haunts me
and they start crying and [ __ ] and
you're like this guy just because he
because he probably told the family i'm
i'm doing everything and then and that
family doesn't have answers right and
he's and now he's now his feet are up in
florida and it's it's killing him sure
which is which is
could your feet be up if you didn't
capture that the big the whale like you
know they said the only one that really
bothered me that one that i tell you
about that
i know she did it and we still haven't
been able to prove it she's still out
freezing she's talking about that so
paul thank you for coming in
thank you so much for having me paul
verzi is a uh actor he's a comedian he
is uh yeah a very talented individual
and also let's say
is my big fat greek wedding to you like
the man walking on the moon
is it uh what's the reality because you
know you know latinos we use vicks we
use right right but but as a as uh using
ethnicity as comedy man like what well
you have so so that's a that's a funny
question because my father is 100
sicilian my mother's 100 greek now my
father
first of all if you ordered that [ __ ] as
as a pizza you're [ __ ] six days you'd
be like
if you got acid reflux [ __ ] that [ __ ]
both of those two [ __ ] combinations
man yeah but my father was sicilian to
the point where he told us sicilians are
the best better than northern italy
sicilians are the best they're the
toughest they're the most loyal
entrepreneurs from sicily yes so yeah my
father lived that my father lived that
you know jewelry i talk about a lot in
the special um the netflix yeah a lot of
things like when people
reviewed or talked about my my netflix
special man the thing with your dad
really resonated because my dad had that
prep now my mother who was 100 greek she
didn't push the greek on to me because
my grandmother was so
much on my mother with it that my mother
pushed it away
so so my greek grandma all greeks and my
mother was like they kind of had a
little bit of a not in a bad way but
like no no but the thing is here we
don't like to just gleam over things uh
describe your grandmother to me
my greek grandmother
everything
great was greek
she would be delusional remember he said
his father said everything great we're
[ __ ] silly so so my grandmother rest
her soul she lived in 99 she was she
lived in 99 years old she
the thing about greeks is greeks their
their body goes forever the mind will go
it's like an engine it's like a car that
rusts around the engine but the engine
but it's the opposite still starts but
it's not going anywhere yeah yeah so my
great-grandmother would be like like she
watched something on tv i'm not i'm not
even joking she watched somebody she
goes you see that singer she'd be like
he's good
he must be greek it was [ __ ] fine
like lionel richie no no i can see his
hair that's greek
greek like that's that so but my mom
since my mom rebelled
she my mom didn't take the greek thing
but my father and me you know told you
you know that's the hardest i left on
this [ __ ] podcast how long have you
been a year and a half yeah that's the
[ __ ] hardest i've laughed oh man well
that means a lot man because
and what did she wear every day like did
she wear she had her look every day
that's a [ __ ] perfect question every
day
every every day lived alone my
grandfather rested so my grandfather
died young obviously my grandfather died
and i want to say 1987. he he he had a
heart attack uh he was only 16. you
still remember
he was he yeah he was everybody 66 is
[ __ ] young everybody says everybody
says that he was me my great grandfather
they were like all everyone's like oh my
god that's gus so his real name was
constantine but everybody called him gus
and wait a minute i can understand why
custom concept team yeah okay let's say
let's say this about america man yeah
they changed people's names when they
got to ellis island and his name was
constantine and they called him
yeah my grandfather worked in
construction wasn't my biological
grandfather by second but he was the one
who raised me his name was refugio like
refugio and he would come back with his
helmet
and it would say rudy on it
[Laughter]
and then the next job remember the label
maker with a circle
nobody could match him up there'd be
[ __ ] three [ __ ] four names ralph
and all with the r but but but
constantine yeah constitute his custody
he [ __ ] gus yeah yeah
he was the best man he was the best he
would he would go in he would always
joke with my joke at my grandmother like
he they because my grandmother was very
proper you know every day even when my
grandfather passed hair done like she
was going out right hair done she'd make
her toast and and her breakfast and sit
down and have her coffee but dressed to
the nines nobody's gonna see her just
but that's what it the pride that's what
it was and she was very very big on that
you know what that goes back to
something that's that sounds like no i'm
kidding that sounds like my wife and me
i'm the crude rude you know do any say
anything do anything i want she's the
prim and proper won't go out won't be
seen doesn't open the door until
everything's perfect all in place that's
a pride thing too it's uh you know i
think it's uh do you know where it goes
back like her what what were her parents
what did her parents do
you know they weren't in the united
states
right because they no they left greece
and i think when they i think when they
came to greece it wasn't they ended they
started in washington heights in new
york but i think they first went to new
hampshire and then from new hampshire
they went to washington heights and they
grew up there for a while but i don't
know exactly what my great on the greek
side i don't really know what my
great-grandparents did
um but the greek pride stuck with my
grandmother and my my mother has one
sister so i have one aunt and she was a
younger one and they were my mom says
you know they're a little harder my mom
was the first one the oldest daughter a
little harder so she pushed the greek
away how about the younger girls how
about your aunt does she my my aunt yeah
my aunt is she's not like huge huge
greek but she didn't butt heads with my
grandmother the way my mother did that's
a great movie the my my fat greek
wedding whatever yeah yeah that was a
great but also she was getting she would
have never considered remarrying right
who's that i think your grandmother
never never like they never
no
never one thing i saw which was pretty
amazing was when i visited her and she
went to a home in her she started
getting a little dementia but late so it
wasn't that bad it was probably you know
in her late 80s but when she went to a
home and she like had friends yeah i
remember she would associate like like a
male friend she would say oh that's gus
she would she you know yeah yeah so um
but no she would never like when she was
like sound of mind and like during the
years she would never even consider no
no she just kind of lived on her own and
yeah
tell your story i had a joke that white
ladies would [ __ ] get murdered the
latinas would be like
oh my angel went to heaven did he light
you on fire shot you oh you weren't
there
and then white ladies are driving
back from the funeral and they're going
like double back there's a [ __ ] guy
right there like don't [ __ ] get
remarried in that [ __ ] drop
my mom i had a joke that said you could
be you could the husband could be dead
65 years
they're 110 eating that [ __ ] norms
and they're going there's that [ __ ]
trot my brother hasn't been dead 65 [ __ ]
a year she's going out with some other
guy
it's like
no [ __ ] time could ever pass would
make it all right for your grandmother
to be holding hands or having coffee
with a man they'd be like oh yeah
i'm going to tell you a story my mom
you've been trying to tell me for my
kids
when my kid
was young she was about 12 13 years old
she my mom sat her down she said i know
your mother won't tell you this but i am
i've had six daughters
be careful those boys all they want is
[ __ ] willow
they'll promise you everything you can
see those legs closed they want that
[ __ ] willow you just tell them
[ __ ] will that's what she's that's why
we're all [ __ ] up and my my daughter
said grandma i said no no no no no
catching up grandma nothing they want
that [ __ ] willow so now
my dad passes away
my mom i'm down my mom's house busy this
is about
seven years after my mom passes and i
asked my wife what's going on with my
mom she seems a little nervous she says
she's going out with sam
she's got a dinner date with sam sam
whose wife had passed his daughters grew
up with my sisters they were all friends
live four houses down from us
he's invited her out for dinner and
she's nervous
and so
i said hey mom so i understand you're
going i mean who i didn't want to go out
i didn't want to go on you know what i
said don't worry about mom you go out
you gotta live ahead of you my dad's
gone go ahead have dinner have a good
time my daughter looks he says grandma
just be careful because remember all
they want is that
grandma
but you don't know
yeah man it's like you know so she got
dressed every morning she sat in the
house and she had a routine and she had
a routine she'd fold the napkins
cleaning house cause you know you could
eat off the floors everything immaculate
she would just sit there and like
because that was her day right she was
alone you know she had a couple of
friends they would play like bridge like
one day or something but other than that
it was like so getting up and doing that
made her feel like the day was kind of
normal because you gotta you gotta have
but i mean she's dressed like
yeah she did dress she did her she did
her hair like she was in her hair ever
did she go to a place where she did her
own hair like all the ladies like in san
fernando would go to la casa coffieres
and uh oh not my grandma no she did
wrong going to the bathroom she would
take a shower do her thing and she would
she would do it all and she'd put this
she'd put like a pearl necklace on and
do that thing and take care of the
kitchen and yeah did you ever see your
grandmother with wet hair never
never my my wife won't even
i'm not i mean i'm not gonna say on on
on the air that she puts red [ __ ] in her
hair
but
she she doesn't even allow me to see her
hannah like that i don't know what she i
never saw my grandmother in pajamas i
never saw her and now that you say that
i never saw her in anything other than
than what you would go out in you know
what man if you were watching a sitcom
man and you had a sitcom where the
grandmother would never saw in pajamas
and never saw her other than dress
tonight and if you did it right it would
be
it's it's all in the family [ __ ] yeah
yeah because
they're never going to let you see them
like that and that's
it's rare yeah but the men are different
my father would eat spaghetti and
meatballs and tidy whities and [ __ ]
that's where the guy he'd come in tight
he waited to start eating
how was your dad and your and and him
and him with your grandmother
was was he a prince or was he that are
not or you mean with with my italian
with his parents yeah it wasn't he was
he was he was jesus he was jesus christ
you know he was just he was just you
know as because he always dressed nicely
and that's the thing there was a line in
the sopranos i don't know if you
remember but there was nothing
if i remember there was a line in the
sopranos where meadows you want to talk
about what what i know about i'm not
going to even try to compare there was a
line in the sopranos where uh
meadow and aj are in aj's room bedroom
and meadow looked and she said you're
you know she said uh you're a boy you're
in a sicilian family you're always gonna
be first you know you know and and that
was kind of that's kind of the you know
and he was first born so it was even
more he's the firstborn sicilian family
man it was just and he dressed nice he
dressed the party looked apart handsome
guy very you know one of those so yeah
he got away with or he can be a certain
way you know and isn't it crazy like
yeah it's wild can can you vividly
remember what his clothes look like his
shoes
shine and sucks you know i had an uncle
johnny i'm not sure he was really my
uncle johnny but
uh he would come over on sundays
occasionally he lived in everybody you
say by the way everybody you say you go
it's not biological
and uncle johnny had a big wife had a
lot of kids but he was flaquito with a
[ __ ]
brown pressed [ __ ] hat skinny dude
[ __ ] shoes shiny thin socks you know
yeah the the the socks the seat through
the nylon socks and that was on a sunday
like you never saw that dude without
without being dressed and his old lady
got out of here
you know i [ __ ] had to help her get
out of the car oh yeah but uncle johnny
you know
my father just always my father would
say a man needs a nice watch
shoes
a nice car
he would look at red lights he would
look at bad cars and go look at this
[ __ ] guy
that's a [ __ ] grown man
there's kids in that [ __ ] grove
there's kids in that car god forbid you
know like he was yeah
he was just a very you know he was very
polished up my father the thing that we
didn't do because they got divorced when
i was five so i visited my father but
but my father was where did he live
where did he live he was well he was
born born in in the bronx area yeah you
know he had his own apartment and he was
yeah so then when they got divorced
silk pajamas his pajamas had to be yeah
his name yeah his initials oh his
initials engraved in his slippers and
[ __ ] like he was a prince yeah it was
crazy but did he did he uh
no okay no no no no that's you know that
yeah yeah none none of that but just is
just very
you know very buttoned up and that's
what it had to be and and you know but
the jewelry was just
heard that word
so he would like so instead of like you
know thing what could you i'm trying to
think instead of bonding with i put it
this way i would have bonded with my
father better
if if i was into jewelry because like he
would be you know he could talk to you
about watches and chains for i mean
forever just diamonds he knows you know
all that stuff but i was a kid i was
into football basketball and [ __ ] i
wasn't he wasn't he wasn't not really
like he took me to like one or two games
but like i knew that he was doing it
just for me like he wasn't into it we
couldn't bond over hey don mattingly on
the yankees when i was like we couldn't
do that you know but if i said dad man
look at that watch right he would be
like that's what i'm you know then he
would was it was it was he into like um
were they both of us were they longines
that's where they roll it yeah more of
like the more of the rolex uh you know
yeah rolex's yeah but now he's like now
he's a little older what's the one that
they do on tv the infomercial the uh the
invicta so now he's got like 60 invictas
just because they got their because the
thing is what my father is [ __ ] vic
he has 16 victories now he's got like
he's got like and it's all a
presentation you buy one that
[ __ ] you can't it he likes the
the it's huge he likes the presentation
of them and i think since he's older now
and he doesn't really go he's just the
big thing so the invicta got him yeah
and he's still living you you you talk
to him you see him yeah i still i still
talk to him i still talk to my dad you
know all the time but like i said it was
a different relationship you're not only
a child are you no no okay so how are
your brothers and sisters or so my older
my older brother christian who's the
firstborn he's five years older than me
okay uh we have the same mother and
father then my parents got divorced and
my mother remarried and had had two so
uh my brother stephen and sister carissa
but they're like nine and ten years
younger um but christian and i same
mother same father christian
christian protected me if i'm being
honest like because he saw a lot of evil
[ __ ] in the divorce um you know i don't
want to say evil like my parents know
that they could but they they saw he saw
more because i'm five six and he's like
11 12 so he got to see like you know and
fighting in the early 80s and [ __ ] it
was different than like it wasn't as
common as like divorce now is kind of
more common yeah you know in the early
80s and my father was a you know but
also if you're [ __ ] yelling at each
other in a neighborhood every all your
neighbors can see the door slam or
somebody say [ __ ] [ __ ] you get in the
car and you take off like your family
knows like all this you know what i
remember you guys will appreciate this i
remember my father had 1982
so my father was a big wig at aig he was
a big wig at aig probably like third or
fourth went like we had we had a tutor
he was third or fourth like yeah he was
like one of the guys at aig okay and he
was you know smart smart guy um and he
and he had a we had a tutor in scarsdale
which is like it was really nice right
oh yeah so my father had a my father had
a brand new but he my father cared about
materialistic [ __ ] he and he wanted
people to see
him so he had him and how did he get in
aig like he was he
was he like a young guy smart dude
he didn't go to college for four years
after he graduated and then he went to
college so he waited he worked he worked
he worked at a howard johnson's okay
making you know getting tips doing all
that bought himself his first waiter or
bartender i think he was i think he was
a waiter and he saved his money he
always bought the nicest clothes bought
his first car a chevy he was very proud
that he saved his money at howard
johnson's bought a chevy did all that
but then he decided to go to college uh
went to university of new mexico and
then came back and finished at iona did
well
and got this job at aig gets married him
and my mother get this tutor in
scarsdale and my life would be probably
wouldn't be a comedian you know if this
if the things didn't go the way they
went but you know let's say that you
know when you when you spend when you
decide
to spend which was really a kind of a
gap four years yeah like he said i'm
gonna go work at howard johnson's i'm
gonna figure out what what the [ __ ] i
want to do where am i gonna go because
usually people go to college for two or
three years if they drop out then they
end up at howard johnson's and that's
the rest of their life
he went to howard johnson's first and
said let me [ __ ] figure out what i
want to do and he did he said his money
he he bought the things that he liked
and then he decided to but he was smart
because i think he saw what was going on
vietnam yeah and i think when he saw
what was going on vietnam and he
realized that like when i stopped i mean
i'm just guessing we never really fully
spoke about it but i remember here in
vietnam and i think he saw that that's
kind of we're losing people it's kind of
a lost and he's like well let me what am
i going to do in my life because it was
either you go into the so he was like
you know what i i felt what it was like
to be out of school for four years in
the workforce let me go a family member
said my father's very prideful a family
member said to him about my father he
would never last in college he'd be back
in a month and my father said yeah and
he went and got all eight
he got all a's and he said yeah yeah he
said women were
my father good looking man so he said
women he's told me this one story he
goes paul i had this blonde knocking on
my door with a bottle of wine and he
goes i had to study i had to get an a
and he [ __ ] and he and he did right so
anyway we're he turned her down oh he
was like well he was he probably knowing
my father he's probably like give me two
hours let me finish it
he ain't gonna turn it all the way down
yeah give me two hours i'll meet you at
the party i gotta finish this [ __ ]
book
so
uh he gets uh i'll never forget this he
gets a black
uh jaguar xj6 white leather me and my
father
oh you are oh no white leather is my
[ __ ] that's it
so my we start backing out our neighbors
i never forget
we had these jewish neighbors who were
they were also materialistic and then my
father so but there are little girls
outside paul where are you going i roll
the back window down me and my brother
in the back of the jaguar my mother and
father are thing and my father's you
know taking us to mcdonald's so i'm
excited so i roll the window down i
start bragging i mean i'm we're going to
mcdonald my dad don't tell him where to
don't tell him we're going to mcdonald's
you don't tell him we're going to
mcdonald's you tell him we're going to a
steakhouse you might roll the don't tell
him that [ __ ] he was like that you know
he was very much like that whole but i
think it's a different time but you know
what man like like what but what led you
to like how did you find comedy like
what it was all it was all um and i've
said this before man it was eddie murphy
so 1987 my father so our visitation days
were uh sunday
courts courts in the 80s only gave my
father 12 hours a week with his boys
and and there was no like abuse or
cheating it was just you know that the
courts were for the women so we had
eight hours on sunday so all day sunday
and then we had dinner with them on
wednesday from like five to eight we
were with them on wednesday right
so anymore and then at the at the at the
end of four hours would it
would you guys be like we got to go like
you couldn't stay
so no no like they would no like if my
mother would never
but it was just you know and it was it
was weird and it was hard on my dad and
my dad being you know italian and
against divorce he was just he was
completely couldn't believe it do you
know do you know like the way that i
grew up like
when i hear you say
eight hours and four hours on wednesday
part of me inside wants to cry man
because yes i know what you know you
feel sorry for your dad you can see what
it's like to have the kids leave
because they have to because they have
to leave yeah yeah
yeah because like your kids believe it
is it it was you know it definitely you
know was was hard on him but the cool
thing was both of my parents in this
weird way comedy you know johnny carson
would be on the tv saturday night live
eddie murphy my father loved rodney
[ __ ] great so rodney so we saw back
to school and my father took me and my
brother to see i was in radio city
musical when rodney was on stage i felt
by the end i by the end
of ronnie
by the end i fell asleep but there was
something there but when raw came out i
was a little kid when raw came out in
1987 i was 29 years old and my
grandmother and mother go you said to my
father you cannot take it you could not
take care of the yonkers it was movie
landing
say yonkers
and movie land was the [ __ ] that was the
place and they said you cannot take this
your son you probably shouldn't take
either of them but paul you know my
brother at the time was almost 15 but
you know but you can't take paul to see
raw and my dad's like [ __ ] take you
to see it and i remember i remember
because that was when that was beverly
hills cop 48 hours you know that was
that was the eddie murphy was eddie
murphy yeah rockstar [ __ ] that was after
delirious sure so a lot of people in
comedy for them my like my friends
they're a lot of my friends in comedy a
little older so for them it was
delirious but for me it was it was raw
yeah and i watched it and i just was
like man and that so then in school girl
i moved a lot my parents after the
divorce i moved a lot so people love the
way oh let paul tell that story i would
tell stories i would try to do and pray
i would just talk and i think my
insecurity and my my anxiety that's what
kind of got me you know let's do it so
then yeah i did an open mic when i was
21 years old and you know to come all
the way here i had a comedy central
special in 18 which did good but to have
netflix for to have netflix see this one
and say this one belongs here and to
have it do what it's doing now um i i
got emotional man like i've been in this
20 years i've been doing it a long time
and but good guys in the business like
bill burr telling me saying things like
man you're coming dude it's just you
know somebody like you you're going the
the real way and it's a little longer
but but you know but it's better because
it made me it made me ready and then
when we put this out and netflix saw it
they were like let's do it and it was
kind of life-changing and it was a long
time my wife stuck with me two kids so
you know i'm not telling you i don't
know but it's a very it's a it's a
commitment that you have to make have
you ever heard me do rodney dangerfield
no
i'll tell you
[Laughter]
i
was at rodney dangerfield's funeral
and i knew him and
i saw i went to go see him perform in
bally's in the 80s
and dennis blair opened and wow we were
in a line in the casino so the line is
going through the [ __ ] slot machines
and you see these two security guards
and the little guy and they're like um
there's a [ __ ] old dude hunched down
like this he's walking his [ __ ]
rodney so he's walking backstage at
bally's
and people are yelling rodney he's a
[ __ ] old guy he wasn't yeah
the best
on a sunday night i was at working at
bali's on a sunday night rodney was
doing a private show
and the everybody was in the kitchen
looking to the side door
and i saw him tell 12 jokes in a row
and every joke was better than the last
so the audience is going boom boom
boom boom boom boom and when you don't
think it could get any [ __ ] higher he
goes the story of my life i don't know
any [ __ ]
nuts
it's one of the most beautiful things
that i've ever seen in my with my own
eyes for a comedian it's funny that you
said that because my father was laughing
so hard at radio city but he was
laughing at another guy laughing at
rodney because the guy couldn't catch
the next joke so he said he said he's
laughing so hard
to try to come down and he was living so
my dad's laughing but my dad's looking
at this guy who couldn't because the
thing about remember that the one that
he did on carson where he'd go and do
was five minutes and then he'd sit on
the couch and then 40 of them he would
just rattle four
you see remember remember you would see
his [ __ ] leg yeah yeah and he had the
[ __ ] socks he would not tell you huh
i didn't know toast had bones
i love when he yeah i love when he would
say things like last we got a rough one
but i'm doing okay now hey so how was it
i'll tell you last week
so carlos santana so when jay leno takes
over from the tonight show nobody knows
this story what year was that in the uh
92-93
takes over
the tonight show calls carlos santana
said we would like for you to be on one
of the early shows that jay leno was
hosting he's like not interested
they call him back santana didn't really
do things
he said i'll do it under one condition
that you go into the tonight show
archives and you send me every
appearance of rodney dangerfield on
tonight's show wow
and he had a cd
wow i went to carlos santana's house in
san rafael he had a church they called
it the church because that all the music
he had a big screen nobody knows this he
had a big screen and he would play with
john coltrane and miles davis wow so
santana would say mr miles davis mr john
coltrane and he those are my friends and
i play with my friends in the middle of
the night he plays the guitar and he
plays
with them wow but he loved rodney and he
and i sat there drinking [ __ ] coronas
watching rodney dangerfield and i took
him a [ __ ] doll where you pushing oh
all right
yes i remember that i remember and and i
brought him that [ __ ] doll as a gift
and
he would he would [ __ ] push that
thing in it you know um
that's amazing how about that story
the church up there in san rafael
and
i said to him you know there wasn't a
lot of gold records on on the walls or
anything and i said
uh
do you put anything up here that reminds
you of what you've done he goes oh hi
yes
yeah this there there was a plaque and
it said this
this
eggnog this acknowledges that
supernatural the album has sold
a hundred million albums worldwide it
was a plaque that was this big on the
wall and you would be like seems like
he's a humble guy yeah and he goes oh
also i have this and he opens it up
there's [ __ ] eight grammys that he
won for supernatural at the same [ __ ]
night
all right all right
but you know he and i went upstairs and
he had a uh um like this was for he gave
me the day he wore this on stage he gave
me this but he also had these artists
like he would find young artists that
would do this it's all like [ __ ]
hand-painted [ __ ] yeah so he sent this
to me
and then
he had a bunch of t-shirts like the
thing i wore last week with the thing
but he would have a guy draw [ __ ] for
him he would hire a chicano artist in
san francisco to draw stuff and that's
the stuff he wears on stage it's miles
david or marley or hendrix but not him
oh wow wow that's that's you know maybe
think about it when you did his voice
all these greats right prince michael
jackson even when uh jamie foxx was
talking when he talked to r uh ray
charles talk low they all talk like they
all have that they all had a decision
you don't have like a hey how you like
you know when you listen to them and
then they go out there and just
like you know man
it's you know
it's funny man because you know it's
saying like you're you know your family
like all of the things that go wrong in
your life
if you are willing to take a chance
yeah if you're willing to risk what's
what makes you uncomfortable and what
makes you scared and what makes you cry
and what hurts you
there could be possibly a payoff where
now all of those things bring you
[ __ ] happiness and joy right your
father that guy saying that you're gonna
end up on the [ __ ] street you go to
vietnam you come back yeah
and and you know you're married 51 years
you have the thing you see the thing
yeah you start to see you see your
grandmother you see your grandfather you
see your dad all these things that
hurt to even see yes
they hurt you to watch yeah and then at
some point you find that your dad listen
your dad love comedy that's how you
found it your dad doesn't like comedy
it's a harder find
the fact that your dad took you to
[ __ ] radio city music hall to see
rodney dangerfield she's wrong when
[ __ ] nope when [ __ ] no father
would do that yeah no i went to see rob
the first day came out i went by myself
and i went to valencia and saw like in
11 40 a.m wow and i loved eddie murphy
yeah and i was working during the day
so i worked during the day and they had
a time magazine eddie murphy was on the
cover and it was a engineer's magazine
so i went to the copy machine and i
i printed before he got in there all the
pages of the article
and i kept the pages article i put the
magazine back for him
and then you love eddie murphy i paid to
see him
in the 80s
and then
uh a few years ago where charlie was
still alive god rest his soul
yeah
that we did the forum and eddie came to
my house and charlie and eddie spent
like six hours together
if you smoke weed in my media room whoa
and uh
to think that eddie murphy would be in
my house
when i was a planner and i would run
articles of him just so i didn't have to
steal the magazine back and still read
the article is
all of the [ __ ] that hurts us if you're
willing to risk yeah and and willing to
be alone yeah and willing to not have
people go with you like
hey man come with me to the club oh man
i got to work in the morning and then
you either say well [ __ ] it i'm not
going or you go or you go yeah and even
if my father was being selfish by saying
i want to see eddie murphy so i'm going
to take my young kid that i'll take that
but you know it doesn't matter that's
where haters come from what you just
said because what a hater does people
that criticize and people that hate they
didn't take that risk and then they see
somebody that did and then what they're
doing is they're projecting they're just
projecting because you went to the club
that night or you decided to go i'm
gonna do this open mic and it's scary
but it's not one time it's [ __ ]
hundreds those [ __ ] can say to
you you suck but it's [ __ ] hundreds
they're not even giving you the credit
of they're just saying um you're not
funny you suck but they're not there in
those nights where yeah you can't find a
place to park it's [ __ ] raining you
got to run in
you you're running behind you call the
place hey man hang on this that guy
[ __ ] eats it before you whatever
and they're not there for it's too easy
to [ __ ] hate like sure they would
have wanted to do it it's easy but it's
it's it's easy it's it's it's it's and
it's such a waste but also also
like
to go like
do you remember being in line to get
into the radio city like you remember
[ __ ] cities i remember the i remember
the chaos before it started wow i wanna
say i think i think if my memory i was
young and it's it's kind of vague it's v
it's not vivid i want to say bob nelson
came out i want to say bob nelson
yeah bob nelson it could have been
dennis blair he was bob nelson because
of the young comedian special bob nelson
did jiffy jeff with the hell he came out
and he put the balloons in his shoulders
i want to say that i want to say that
nelson came out and i remember that i
remember we were sitting in the balcony
here's a crazy story here's a crazy
story
me and my father were in a comedy room
together two times ever
one
when me and him are in the balcony with
my older brother to watch rodney after
back to school came out and the second
time my father was in the balcony
watching me open for billboard carnegie
hall that was the second time
that was the second time and my father
and my father and my father still only
that's the only time my father you know
had watched me uh my father watched my
special on tv you know and he called and
he was like you know that was great you
know he's he's a a critical guy but he
was great with it you know what he's a
critical guy
if he didn't like him he would have very
ve he would have told me and he would
have told him he would say hey man he
would have been like paul you know i
love you my son he would he always
prefaces it he was prefacing
listen you know i love you not for
anything and then he would just he would
go away well that's what i talk about on
my on my
thing well on my special nocturnal
admissions my father when he was upset
because he loved us so sicilians it's
they can't be mad at you if they love
you and my father didn't love anybody
more than he loved me and my brother so
he couldn't be mad because it looked
like it was like bad for the family so
he would say i'm a little confused that
was the thing
hey i saw this thing i'm a little i'm a
little just just help me out like that
would mean
what the [ __ ] is this
they're not dumb but they're playing
them because they're they're trying to
get their friends
right right like so what about uh help
me understand that right right now for
nothing so my daughter my daughter's
name is sophia aaron my daughter's name
is sophia aaron verzie okay
my dad calls me up
beautiful congratulations baby girl you
named her sophia
like sophia loren
that's that's beautiful he goes
but then i noticed just i'm a little
aaron that's irish where the [ __ ] does
that come from
e-r-i-n yeah and a-and that
what sophia versus beautiful time why
you throw irish in the middle enough
don't get excited then you always say i
don't get upset don't get upset
don't get excited but what the [ __ ] is
irish doing and i'm like my wife you
know my wife so like so for him he was
so forget my wife's side forget any of
that it's got to be his thing you know
so that so when he was upset so like he
if i never did a bit like when he called
he called after the special i knew he
saw it and i'm so proud you know you got
a good way of doing this but he said to
me he goes man he goes if i didn't like
it you know because that's the reason
some people didn't like my dad because
my dad was my dad was a very my dad was
very much like [ __ ] that you know like
my dad my dad saw the um
the chris rocket slapped you know and my
dad my dad's a street kid like not a
street kid but my dad's like no you got
a fight what's he doing you got and i'm
like well dad he was in a situation like
my dad won't
yeah his dad said
he's got a [ __ ] what's he doing yeah
another [ __ ] guy hit you
right so it was in my so i tried to tell
you know dad chris rock is at the oscars
he got taken by i don't know nah [ __ ]
that we don't [ __ ] do that i would
have [ __ ] i'd have been arrested
okay like i would have jumped in i would
have beat him in the crowd like that so
my dad couldn't he's just one of those
you know you can't you can't really talk
you know how [ __ ] much you know how
much i would [ __ ] love to be sitting
around his dad and outside drinking big
oil hey george you're a comedian what
the [ __ ]
would you not have [ __ ] slapped his
ass no my dad my dad i tell you right
now my dad my dad would love you and and
i'm sure if my dad saw it saw you
because the way you conduct yourself the
way you are if there's that old school
thing my dad and you know i saw you know
you dress not you know what i mean like
my dad would be like you know i have
good watches
yeah yeah you like oh look at his shoes
this guy knows what he's doing like
that's my dad's you know thing you know
so but yeah it was a different thing to
but i didn't grow up with it all the
time but but um at some point
uh at some point you
you stopped looking at your dad as your
dad and started looking at him as a
[ __ ] muse for comedy
yeah because if he's going hey listen
not for nothing then you know yeah
and i'm not trying to try to get you
upset you know what what the [ __ ] yeah i
mean all of that stuff is [ __ ] that
you can't if you don't see it you can't
write it my i'll tell you guys something
okay i'm working on this for the new
hour but i don't give a [ __ ] i'll tell
you this
but so so this is this you're gonna love
this so my father my father wrote a
letter to haraldo rivera okay listen to
this [ __ ] okay what year the to the son
of samuel no no the [ __ ] a month too
much
less like recently recently yeah
by the way my my parents grew up my
parents grew up where the son of sam
they grew up did they know they grew up
uh
i mean i thought they're my aunt had a
friend who did laundry
my aunt had a friend who was folding
laundry in the laundry place of the
building with with berkowitz um yeah
because that that whole area which is
there and they knew the park that park
that satanic thing that park that was
there that they knew that too so let me
tell you something in the you know
remember the parks on the weekend and
all this stuff so if they would say come
over here lydia come over here tell me
what happened i used to full laundry
where david berkowitz used to [ __ ]
do us alondra the same place what
it was
it's a [ __ ] badge of like of of honor
like bring her over here
you already know the story oh all right
i mean it's like your story it's your
story to tell her yeah yeah um so my
father is very very patriotic and my
father is very very conservative and my
father is very very he's not he does not
take lightly to people bad mouth in the
country for better or worse he's like
american to the point where like even if
america did something that was like a
little maybe we should he's like ah nah
you know yeah you got to do it you got
to look like that right so
your dad's got a friend yeah yeah so my
dad calls me up and my dad goes my dad
goes hey paul
let me say
in america now it's quite a it's quite
an old-fashioned attitude somebody that
stays american sure and that that's what
gets him that and i think that that's
what gets him to start in a row no no no
no no but that's a good thing it's a
good no it's actually a good point you
said because that's kind of what drives
him even nuts now because
what gets him mad is that he sees people
separate a little bit and he sees
national pride go away and looked at us
something bad so
so he calls me up he goes yeah i'm a
little paul i'm a little excited i don't
mean to be
you know and i know he's got he goes i'm
walking around pacing around the [ __ ]
house he's like i you know he goes you
notice geraldo rivera [ __ ] he's like
i go yeah dad i know who we are
oh he goes right he dives right and i go
yeah i know he goes listen to this [ __ ]
he goes
he's on the [ __ ] tv and he just go
now i just have to i'm just are you
doing this you do this in stand up like
you're standing there
no no like yes so like no no this is a
new bit i'm working on but it's true and
it may change but he calls me i go yeah
he goes yeah he's talking negative about
the country he's saying some of the
things they did in the middle east to a
right this [ __ ] hit there's trees in
his [ __ ] he's he's going nuts right he
goes but the good news is
they left an email address on the tv and
they said if anybody wants to contribute
so i decided to write geraldo rivera a
letter he always says his first name the
whole name
so i wrote geraldo rivera letter he goes
can i read it to you he goes i know
you're out there in the world whatever
the [ __ ] that means
i know you're out there in the world so
i'm gonna read this and i don't know
you're up there in the world yeah i
don't know yet you know there's a rather
unfair [ __ ] so i swear to god he reads
it he reads it to me i'm not making this
up i'm not making this up this is what
he said because all right hold on a
second and i could tell he's putting his
glasses on he's looking i could tell and
he goes all right paul here you go he
goes
dear geraldo rivera
you're half a man [ __ ]
how dare you speak about the united
states of america like that your
treasonous [ __ ]
i can't believe they gave an ugly [ __ ]
like you a television show in the first
place with your stupid [ __ ] mustache
if i ever see i'm gonna smack those
sunglasses off your [ __ ] head
you don't deserve this country or to
make money in this country you [ __ ]
half a man [ __ ]
anyways go [ __ ] yourself
sincerely
tom is jay first and then i swear to god
he goes like this he waits a beat and he
goes paul be honest what'd you think
well yeah dad you know what they're
going to read that tonight he's going to
read that on the air tonight you know
you should have made it longer to let
him know you should have made it longer
to let him know how you know you really
feel about it well he'll hear it all
he'll hear it now oh [ __ ]
i think we got a new high water mark
that's the hardest i've
you know left
that's an honor because you're a [ __ ]
legend god bless you hey listen how are
you doing
you need a [ __ ] paragraph
oh [ __ ] miserable and then he just goes
so you know i hope he reads it you know
like he just he just said but in his
mind he needed to in his mind he got so
upset about that and he's you know how
could he talk about he's talk you know
we're in conflicts and you can't do that
he just he just had to do that but that
says
it says a lot i tell you what if i'm
lucky enough i'll be able to meet your
dad and shake his hand one time oh yeah
yeah no you would you would love you
would
he's another he's another breed man he's
he's from another time and uh he's but
he's
he's out to florida
is that where he moved to florida west
point and he'll just call me with
obvious [ __ ] he'll call me with obvious
[ __ ] but he always complained i'll be in
miami the end of this month
he'll call me a big yeah i'm down here
in florida it's just [ __ ] hot down
here
[Music]
and it's humid as [ __ ] but is he where's
he he doesn't live in the villages or
anything like that no no no
you know what i haven't seen him the
villagers everybody all people all [ __ ]
each other like you play golf forever
yeah but they're also [ __ ] each other
do you golf yeah oh do you have do you
yeah
oh you're a 10 okay yeah i'm not playing
all the pro ams and stuff oh dude yeah
you play with santino no i'm like no not
yet i might do his show but i have not i
haven't got i'm like i'm like a 18. you
know i'm like i'm like an eight-year-old
but i don't get to play like i want to
play more yeah you know it's one of
those things where especially when you
do this job i'll go out i'll play three
weeks in a row and i'll start getting
the score down and everything and then
finally also it's great it's a great
sport for us to play because you get
away from everybody and you can hang out
with people and and yeah i smoke cigars
out there and i just have to play man
i'll take you to play santino hit me up
about playing but we'll we'll play him
yeah do you play normally the same
course out here i'm a member at a couple
of clothes oh okay okay yeah yeah nice
i'm a member at a club where
in 1997 i didn't have the right pants to
even get to the gates
i had to buy
and buy clothes to go on the golf course
with him one time i didn't golf i was
just gonna be in a in the cart with him
but he met he was with passion like past
you plays in my in my turn hey
[ __ ] yeah uh he played he plays
uh he plays in my uh
[ __ ]
what are you doing here you're going to
tell me something tough guy wait i
thought i told you go [ __ ] your mother
pal what are you doing i thought you go
[ __ ] that's that's just i mean i i
get you know he sings and all that stuff
you know i i actually saw there was a
pic i saw a picture of him at like 14
years old with like a good touch
yeah that's crazy
you know
didn't he i know quite well frankie
valley yeah
that's amazing yeah i know him quite
well and this is uh also know jack
jack jack nicholson
i should say this story
i told jim brewer and jim brewer told
the story on howard stern and then jim
brewer after he told the story said i
hope you don't mind i told the story
[ __ ] you have to tell me before
not after
so so so
so jack nicholson would play but he was
you know he he'd play
as
he'd move around so him and him and joe
pesci are playing
at lakeside and billy andre who's a pro
misses the cut at the buick open in san
diego drives down and he gets there and
he says oh i might play with mr pesce he
goes oh they're on the putting on the
eighth hole and the ninth hole is a part
three so he takes the card and he goes
around he's kind of laying back and jack
fans went up to the right
and billy andrew who just got there says
i think i'll be able to help jack and he
goes yeah go go yeah go down goes up he
goes he goes jack i think i have a tip
that can help you and jack goes yeah
yeah yeah
everybody's got a tip for jack
well i got a tip for you buddy you could
take that tip and shove it up
so
he goes back to the cart and he walks by
joe and he goes what do you say he goes
nothing because what'd he say
he goes nothing what a manufacturer
saying
he said he told me to go [ __ ] myself
so he walks up to me goes hey your
[ __ ]
my friend i don't care who he is
and he goes that's my friend you're
talking to my friend your [ __ ] you
and your friend can go [ __ ] you
so now he's been there less than five
minutes he's got joe pesci and jack
nicholson nose to nose oh i don't give a
[ __ ] who he is wow he's got know
something like that
uh this was in the mid 90s holy [ __ ]
that would have been something how about
that that's that's amazing now wait i
see you're a because i'm a big knicks
guy you're a big laker guy yeah so okay
yeah and i love the knicks too i i mean
i'm dying for it man
they're going to be good no i'm just
dying for it because we don't need it
man we need it i better roll the pearl
monroe
i mean [ __ ] man oh man those are the
guys well they haven't won since those
guys 73 the knicks one is 77
russell just passed bill
i played golf with bill russell so so
eleven times uh eleven time champion
that doesn't happen you're not gonna see
a guy getting a little bit again okay
let me say this bill russell that
wrestles rest is so they won so many
championships that they stopped giving
rings and
and they would say what do you guys want
like a sofa a tea set they started
giving [ __ ] silver tea sets
because the wives would say they started
getting refrigerators out for winning
the championship wow
so many
i only got two rings they started giving
you a [ __ ] silver t-shirt oh [ __ ]
they won so much
they're like
the ring the ring wasn't the thing well
i'll tell you how crazy is this if tom
brady gets one more and gets eight
that's in the nfl that's unheard of
unheard of i mean i mean five is on her
six is on her but the guy if he gets one
more he's got eight as a quarterback in
today's nfl today's nfl is not the nfl
and when you look at the speed now and
all that and this guy found a way and
he's not a system quarterback too they
say system quarterback i think tom brady
found a way but look he gets to tampa
bay they win the first year he gets that
he leaves he leaves new england after
all 18 years but also
but also he left the way that we [ __ ]
would have left where he said
[ __ ] i made you yeah oh really
yes [ __ ] you you me i wouldn't
have won a [ __ ] quarter i wouldn't
want a super bowl without you i'll show
you
that's exactly right he's left going oh
they're saying i'm a product of this
team and the coach and the system and
then he goes to tampa bay new coach new
team and wins again [ __ ] wins that's
that's man that's incredible no that's
actually that's actually a good point
it's like he basically said to solidify
that it's not them i'm gonna go win on
my own and he did it but because you
know somebody told you and somebody
tells all of us
it's not you i i you know eddie it's
like no [ __ ] anybody could
anybody could have done that no
it's not i you're do you mind if i ask a
question about the crime can i do that
because i was watching the documentaries
i watched these documentaries and i was
watching the son of sam one and i was
just wondering if you had any insight on
this where
they said that the the in the
documentary
there was a murder that he did but
around the same time where he couldn't
get to another place there was another
one and they're saying that that cult
there was instead of it just being the
son of sam he admitted even when he got
i guess mentally better that he had the
majority of them but others were done by
others in that cult is there any truth
to that or
i don't i don't have it because there
were
there was almost like i'm questioning
our guy was he good for other ones or
did other people
do them circumstantially
we didn't care we didn't file any
circumstantial stuff it was only stuff
that we had
good evidence do you think that there
were people sacrificing people like
devilish [ __ ] that they were they were
right well they were definitely
sacrificing german shepherds and dogs
that was a big thing that what they did
they were killing dogs in that park and
they were all signs but he admitted to
out of the six or seven of the women he
admitted to the majority but there was
one or two and then the people that they
said did it one guy died in a single car
crash another guy killed himself another
guy got killed so it just makes sense
yeah and it makes you and the
documentary kind of says it and then
they tried to talk to him and he didn't
you know he didn't want to he didn't
want to talk about it he's holding he's
holding information that
i mean are you such a devotee that
you're going to hold this information
that would really blow the case open
again or you're taking the hit that's
same thing richard said if he had
information that we didn't know
his ego would not let us
know that he wanted to he wanted he was
sharper than us yeah he wanted to show
him see i don't watch that one i
couldn't watch that one and i don't
watch one the ones that i don't watch
are the ones with children i can't
did you ever see mystic river the movie
uh yeah
yeah with uh the clint eastwood movie
with a little growing skill
yeah and then the the then tim robbins
yeah yeah that was
you know when you have kids it's
different well that's the thing i have
little ones and that that's when i can't
when i hear about that stuff i can't
watch the netflix documentary on richard
there's only one kid that's involved
and she lived and now she's in the
documentary about 42 years he let her
live and she's a beautiful she's a
wonderful lady
great lady when you talk to a guy like
that like when you sit down and you talk
to a guy like that are you just like do
you like see the evil like do you feel
that
no no it's all jesus you know what it is
he's another human just like you but you
know what they have like you say if your
dad or anybody these [ __ ] had a
mystique where they were they were
larger than life hey and the shark bite
say babe they get [ __ ]
they're all ego right yeah they're
[ __ ] larger than life well they're
all sharp and they're all charming like
they come in and they seem like they're
like bundy women love the kid they're
[ __ ] and they're [ __ ]
they're set grandiose self grandiose and
then when he got caught he said what he
was just [ __ ] hitting him
nothing more than another human it was
all gone and and like tom brady
you know when people said what was it
like you know tom brady just another guy
out there
a father
a husband yeah a buddy go to a bar
brother yeah on sunday
put that helmet on yeah and it's all
about the game
so
when i went in to talk to richard
everything went out the room it's all
about the game it's now
game time yeah you guys he was caught
like he's
it just now it's me and you and
i need information from you so i gotta
it's game day
so i need to do everything i can put
every trick i have in my pocket to get
him to talk that's all it is and you
want to talk you've got cut that's all
wow
you know there's a there's a there's a
chicano thing you know this guy rich
ramirez is it's in the documentary he
he's shackled
and he's got the two lawyers which were
like novice [ __ ] lawyers
and the d.a is talking about rich
ramirez in front of him and he starts
like a chicano say hey you [ __ ]
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] he's doing this [ __ ]
yeah and
like anybody would say hey man i'm not
going to stand here and let you [ __ ]
talk [ __ ] about me i don't give a [ __ ]
who you think i am and
it's very like from the neighborhood
like you're like you let that dude
[ __ ] say that [ __ ] about you no no
there's no way even though he had done
what he had done you could see
the [ __ ] spirit of it coming out of
him like this guy
yeah that's it's
it's amazing it's it's that's why we
watch so so what is your acting that
what what do you what do you want
what would make you happy like where do
you see yourself for number one for me
to stand up so like the you know each
hour's getting better and this one
having having amazing i've had some
legendary comedians reach out and say
some things about this one so i want to
keep putting hours out but now you know
getting small parts here and there i
like acting but i don't want to act and
pursue acting where i'm going on
auditions and doing that i want to act
where it's like you know if that part
fits me or somebody sees me through my
comedy right you know wants oh i think
you know paul version i saw that that
could be that character could be good
for this but i would say man um just
just you know not to sound corny or
cliche but no my if my kid if my if if
me my wife and my kids are happy and
healthy and i'm and i'm doing what i
love and i'm making
hours of stand up that are getting
better and better and i could get some
parts and some and some things and do
that i do a couple of podcasts man i'm
good so so uh
how long you been married
uh this november will be 15.
and your wife you guys are
in love happy partners yes yes she's
we're so different my wife is just just
my wife's a [ __ ] my wife's
scandinavian but just a bulldog just a
general like anything my wife does she
goes to the top she'll become the vice
president you know she's not greek is
she no no she's like swedish
she's got she's irish she's got uh just
in the neighborhood growing up newer
knew of her just you know and but my
wife is just strong man
my wife is my wife is the is the anchor
she's like the one that she could see
when i start going down a road of you
know because this job is is every
everything in life you know and i dealt
with some mental health things because
of my mom and stuff just anxiety and ocd
and [ __ ] like that so my wife kind of is
she kind of watches out and she's she's
really good donation did it surprise you
that you had anxiety or ocd like a
little bit you know did it surprise you
no because did your dad know my my like
hey what the [ __ ] no what happened
started it started because of the
divorce because i i was stripped of a
lot of security young sure and and i was
always worried something would happen to
my mom my dad was around they were they
were fighting so there would be a we
would have a little like um
pathway through from our living room
would go to their kitchen and there was
a column yeah and when i was in third
grade i would just start walking around
the column and they were going well how
come he's not just walking right through
that i didn't realize but for me it was
like this weird security thing and i'm
in like the third grade so i would just
walk around this thing and uh and then i
would just start doing things and i
would start i would start to feel like i
would need to do something so i would
have the anxiety it was from a little
kid and you know i spoke to doctors and
stuff so now um i have a good
understanding of that i know that i need
to be rested i know that i need to
whether it's talk to somebody or just
but it's gotten to the point rest his
soul kobe bryant man who if you listen
to that kid talk and you listen to his
quotes and but you know he said like
sometimes being your own therapist so
sometimes you know i could say to myself
paul this is what's happening right now
so just kind of you know yeah but that i
think that uh that definitely played but
also if you if you talk to a
professional then you're able to
identify like a detective you're able to
identify
the flags that that are raised when you
go oh okay i need to i need to chill the
[ __ ] out or i need to you know be
careful of this yeah like certain things
i'd be like you know what i'm not gonna
drink for a while i'm not that was ever
a problem but like i just know if i get
tired if i get run down if i'm traveling
a lot i just you know you can just get
yourself you could go down a go down a
path where now i'm strong enough to go
you know what man you need some rest
you're not you know but you know uh and
you have it too um
a woman he's been married 51 years
wow but also wow
you know like they say if you want to go
find a killer to that first year i'd
already been out of the joint
yeah
but to have somebody that
is not an opponent to someone's
path or success you see a lot of times
where
when
when you start to
get some success it starts to threaten
your partner and there's a bit of there
could be a bit of uh
a bit of self imploding or
or getting on someone to a point where
you're trying to prevent them to be
from being the best that they can be
yeah no but it's a [ __ ] subliminal
[ __ ] thing yeah yeah it was opposite
i listened to to my wife she is the
winner she's always been the wind
beneath my mouth she's allowed me
to
to walk
but did you actually say the wind
between beneath your wings yeah the wind
beneath my way she's allowed me to
be in front now
she has said now there's been a push
from some people all i can hear is his
dad hey guilt not for nothing
that's a fart that ain't a [ __ ]
you know they've been trying to get me
to do 10 minutes stand up
oh [ __ ] have you become a
stand-up i'll light you on fire
and and so
you know
they've been saying hey
you know do do stand up we'll help you
we'll write so you know just get up
there dude you're so funny up there when
i get up there with momo and the guys
and i told the wife i said what do you
think about me doing 10 minutes you know
they're asking me
and she just said no
whatever you walk up there you go i know
what you're thinking gabriel glasses
really let himself
go the uh uh but but also it might not
have to be sent up it might just be
hosting like don't say it's that don't
don't give it
don't give it a title
right just say they asked me to
introduce somebody and you slip like
boxing you slip a couple yeah because if
you start a show and say hey welcome to
comme une francaise don't put the
pressure on yourself by saying i want to
be stand-up
just say let me go up you did ring
announcing right let me go up and
you know add a couple in and then you
bring somebody up that's different you
know what man i mean you're you're
[ __ ] great man i think i think you're
great dude i appreciate you and i love
the fact that um
you're willing to take the path less
traveled
yeah you know what i've had like i said
you know to have a mentor and a friend
like a guy like bill burr and even some
other guys that i opened for before i
was headlining just you know let me know
like i wanted to do it the right way
it's a big deal to to to uh
have a guy like or have a headliner
bring a guy because you know it's a it's
it's a
almost like you go hey you have a gold
medal you have the c it's a silver medal
and they're and they're getting the
audience when they're in their
[ __ ] prime maximum you know you're up
there and you're [ __ ] chewing up this
half hour the guy's got to come but
to be able to trust somebody for that
time that you know that you don't burr's
not looking at the corner he can trust
you oh yeah the people that bring you
can trust you for that half hour like
like uh when brian and i worked together
a reuben like it would be half an hour
and it's like dude don't do
27 minutes
don't do 32 minutes do 30 because i'm
all about time i get dressed after i
have people give me
at certain times and i get dressed at a
certain time so if they go short and
they open the door and they say hey man
you're on what i don't know my [ __ ]
tie on
that's them not me yeah yeah so they
know that they have to do their time
because i run by time
yeah it's funny you say that because i
know time so well like my wife will go
how long has it been i'll be like it's
been about 18 minutes and she's like
what the [ __ ] you know we know it but uh
no and and that's the thing i haven't
worked with bill in almost five years
and i remember we're smoking a cigar and
he goes it's great to see you go and do
do your thing and then to go off and do
these specials and stuff and now i'm
bringing guys up and when they see that
i'll tell guys i'll go listen it's one
thing to have a ton of followers because
you do a dance on tick tock okay you do
a dumb dance on tick tock or you do
something like that and you just fill a
club i go it's another thing to have the
time it's another thing to give a
[ __ ] show for an hour so i said if
you depending on what you want to do if
you want to be youtube famous and and do
that great but if you want to be great
at this it there's no shortcuts in this
you know and that's that's that's what
i've that's what's gotten me you know
here and you know what was so gratifying
was we didn't know when the special came
out where it would go and netflix was
even kind of like ah we don't know and
then they saw it and they said this
belongs here and i knew when we knew
when we did it so it was the work and
and and you can't [ __ ] with work you
can't [ __ ] with work and funny and when
it's sustained for 60 minutes that that
just can't be [ __ ] no no you can't
[ __ ] with that the the and the fact that
uh you know the preparation in
is like a surgeon you know the patient
lives but also
when you're trying to prepare an hour
you have
forces of a room service a loud room
whatever the [ __ ] noise but you have to
drown that all out because what matters
is that day like i would do my specials
live because
i was a fan of boxing
so if if it's
which is so unbelievable that you did
that and so ballsy we're in august right
now and they say okay hbo wants to talk
to you they say
july 12th you're going to do a live
special okay so now i go from just
regular comedian to now thinking of
myself as a fighter and i'm fighting
july 12th that's crazy so whatever from
august 1st to july 12th i have to
prepare myself so that july 12th i'm my
best on that night at that particular
time and here's what's even more
incredible about that it's not like
you're doing it on a date where you got
an eight and a ten and they could edit
them together no you're going you're
going another guy a great guy who did
that was brian regan but like you right
one of the best and and such a nice
person but to you know usually when you
do a special you shoot at eight o'clock
and you shoot at 10 o'clock you figure
out one of them was probably 80 90
percent better you may take some
audience from this or that sometimes
when you put together a show going live
is like we're doing this is it that's
when i saw that i was like that's some
next [ __ ] i did america's mexican you
know that and i did it in phoenix
and
this [ __ ] jib camera
went across me and you could see the red
light on the camera and i thought
everybody on hbo is watching me right
now like you see the camera go by and
you see the camera in the back and my
last line was
i had no mother had no father they told
me i couldn't make it they told me i end
up on the street i ended up on the
street on the hollywood walk of fame oh
my god and the thing flashes and i take
the microphone away and i said and
that's right mother under you can see my
you can see me
mouthing yeah because i took the
microphone away wow is that when you say
[ __ ] to yourself yeah that's amazing and
and that was my focus of of uh
of doing the things live have you ever
had a moment on stage this happened to
me a couple times but where you get
emotional but you then all of a sudden
then then all of a sudden it flips i was
on stage it was when i was at carnegie
and i just had talked about having two
little kids and i realized in that
moment even though
i
wasn't a national headliner yet i was
opening for somebody but i i remember
going i'm on the right path and i'm
standing up and i'm killing carnegie
hall and i'm talking about my kids and
all of a sudden i started to and i'm
going you can't [ __ ] cry right now
and my father would have been like the
what the [ __ ] are you crying from a
little no good set but i'm a little you
know
are you [ __ ] crying so but yeah you
can catch yourself in a moment uh uh do
you want to uh do you want to do radio
city on your own
radio city on my own or or or msg yeah
yeah that would be you know that would
be something that i did uh what's msg uh
madison square gardens yeah i did um
i sold out radio city musical three
times wow and once on a saturday and
once again on the next saturday wow and
um
in the in the headliners room they bring
a book and bring a book and they go
you know if you get a chance you know we
have all the headliners signed this book
and the book is sitting there and you're
looking and i get there way early i get
that way earlier than a [ __ ] comedian
[ __ ] 5 30 on my it shows i go up at 9
30.
i'm there at 5 30.
and you start to look through it and you
see
diana ross and you see bruce springsteen
yes and you see the rock cats and then
you see
george gershwin
and [ __ ] artie shaw and benny goodman
in a [ __ ] book that you get to sign
oh my god
wow
i closed that [ __ ] book i said
everybody that came in the room that
said hey what's that book don't open
that [ __ ] book
until the show's until the show's over
man i totally get that you're awesome
man dude thank you so much for having me
i really are [ __ ] great thank you so
much pleasure man honor me pleasure
what are we talking about what special
are we talking about
uh netflix nocturnal admissions
streaming right now on netflix which is
a great time you know what nocturnal
missions is a wet dream
yeah but this one is admissions so
yeah yeah so uh nocturnal admissions
it's it's streaming right now it's doing
well you can check that out
and uh
not turtle vision
uh check out paulversie.com my my
podcast uh the virzie effect i also
co-host a podcast called anything better
with bill burr and uh yeah man check out
my dates i'm traveling so that all this
stuff is on paul versus uh you know dr
[ __ ] paul bersie i appreciate it i
know man awesome thank you
you